>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> John Fenn III: So I'm John
Fenn, the Head of Research
in Programs at the
American Folklife Center.
We're here on the Coolidge
Stage with the Fairfield Four,
and I'm going to ask you guys
each to introduce yourselves
and say how long you've
been singing with the group.
We'll start with you, sir.
Yeah.
>> Leveret Allison: My
name is Leveret Allison.
I've been singing with
the Fairfield Four
for about eight years.
>> John Fenn III: Okay.
>> Bobbye Sherrell: My name is
Bobbye Sherrell, and I started
with the group, I think, 2011.
So that would be seven --
six and a half, seven
years ago member.
>> John Fenn III: Okay.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.:
My name is Larrice Byrd.
I've been singing with
the group eight years.
>> Joe Thompson: And
I'm Joe Thompson.
I've been off and on with the
group just about all my life.
But this group, we've been
together about eight years.
>> John Fenn III: Okay, and
this is the third generation?
>> Joe Thompson: Right.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: Correct.
>> John Fenn III: Now so
the group has been active
as an entity -- I don't know
what other word to use --
for about 95 years, right?
>> Larrice Byrd,
Sr.: That's correct.
>> John Fenn III: So what
brought all of you to the group?
What pulled you into
it, this guy over here?
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.:
Yeah, this guy here.
>> Joe Thompson: Well,
a lot of the other guys
from the second generation, they
started passing on, you know.
So I was part of it, generation
two, so when it got down to me,
and I'm about the last one
living -- myself and Robert --
so they asked them could
I keep the group going?
So they give me their blessing.
So I called Leveret, and I
saw Byrd, and I said, "Well,
now we need a tenor singer."
So Leveret and I, we were
racking our brains trying
to find a tenor singer,
somebody that was dependable
and could do -- keep
the old tradition going.
And one day I saw
Bobbye at the store,
and I said, "Thank you, Jesus.
There's my tenor
singer right there."
And we've been here ever since.
>> John Fenn III: So who
brought you into the group?
>> Joe Thompson: Back -- this
-- Sam did most of it then,
but Robert saw me the
last time, and I think one
of the -- James Hill passed.
And then Robert called me
and asked me would I come in.
That's when I came
and stayed this time.
>> John Fenn III: Does anyone
know the origin of the name
of the group, Fairfield Four?
>> Joe Thompson: It
started in South Nashville.
The name of the church was the
old Fairfield Baptist Church,
and the group started
right there.
>> John Fenn III: Okay,
and as we learned earlier
today during the concert,
started out as a trio.
>> Joe Thompson: Right.
>> John Fenn III: Sometimes
it grows past a quartet.
So is the name Fairfield
Four just kind
of an average number of members?
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: Yes,
I've seen the group
up to seven members.
>> John Fenn III: Seven members?
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: Mm-hmm.
>> John Fenn III: And so
are they doing seven-part
harmony there?
What's -- how are they
splitting that up when --
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: Well,
I think what happens is
they're constantly --
if somebody gets sick, they're
finding someone to replace them
for a certain time or period.
And then when they -- the other
person gets back on his feet,
they -- the other guy did
so well that they decide
to keep him in the group.
>> John Fenn III: Okay.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.:
And then we're --
you know, we're the youngest --
probably the youngest group
of the Fairfield Four.
And while -- since they're
up in age, you know,
there are some days
your knees don't move --
work like they should, and
they can't go on the gig.
So you know what I'm saying?
>> John Fenn III:
So someone else --
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: It
was good to have a spare.
>> John Fenn III:
Oh, that's fantastic.
Now I want to ask each of you --
and maybe we'll start
with Mr. Thompson --
when did you feel that
you were a bass singer?
Like when did you find each of
your voices, because you have
such beautiful harmony?
When did you know?
>> Joe Thompson: I was
the baritone singer
in the other part --
>> John Fenn III: Okay.
>> Joe Thompson: -- and when
Dickey [assumed spelling]
passed, couldn't find a
good bass singer nowhere.
So I just said, "Well,
heck, I'll try it."
And so I didn't quite
know all of the stuff.
It was thanks to Mr. Byrd
here, Brother Bobbye there,
they've been coaching me on some
of those notes that
I need to hit.
So [inaudible] got
me going pretty good.
>> John Fenn III: Okay,
what about you, Byrd?
>> Larrice Byrd,
Sr.: Now, you know,
after you grow past your
childhood and teenage years,
your voice changes anyway.
So I got to the point
where I was an adult --
a young adult, and my
voice ended up here.
I noticed I couldn't hit
a lot of the high notes
that the tenor singers sing,
so I just got comfortable
in this area singing baritone.
And that's where I'm
really comfortable now.
>> John Fenn III: Okay,
so you find your fit?
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.:
Yes, found my fit,
and I stayed in that box.
>> Bobbye Sherrell: I guess I've
been a tenor singer all my life,
really, either a high
tenor or a mid-tenor.
And so my range is --
really hasn't changed.
It's gotten stronger
over the years, oh yeah.
So to say the least, I'm
tenor -- been tenor, still is.
>> John Fenn III:
And what about you?
>> Leveret Allison: I've also
always been classified myself
as a tenor singer
and lead singer.
And that's where I've
mostly been all my life.
And that's where I've stayed.
>> John Fenn III: So singing,
music, has it been part
of your lives growing up?
Is -- in this tradition?
Multiple musics?
Let's hear a little about
musical background for everyone.
>> Joe Thompson: We're
all similar backgrounds.
[Inaudible] the same,
we was all brought
up in church, singing families.
And so it was real easy
for us to get together.
>> John Fenn III:
Speak in the mic.
>> Joe Thompson: Oh, I'm sorry.
>> Larrice Byrd,
Sr.: Well, now I'm --
these guys are from Tennessee.
I'm from South Florida.
>> John Fenn III: Okay.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: And
it's -- South Florida is --
I grew up in an area -- I
mean, South Florida is just
like a melting pot, there's so
many different nationalities
and stuff, because I
remember in elementary school,
you had a Chinese,
Spanish, Mexican,
just everything, blacks, whites.
So I got used to hearing --
and then, the radio
played everything.
It wasn't just one
type of music.
And I'm really a
musician by trade.
They pulled me in as a vocalist,
but I'm more of a musician.
But I love it, and I'm --
like I said, growing up,
I experienced it all.
So I became comfortable
singing or playing,
dealing with all
types of music, so.
Oh, here's one other thing
about the four of us,
we all grew up in a
similar-type home.
After talking with each
other, meeting these guys,
our parents were in church,
and we heard gospel
music all the time.
So we were exposed to stuff
beyond our age, you know,
listening to their music --
listening to our parents' music.
So I guess --
>> John Fenn III: So
it was all around?
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: Yeah, I
guess the gift was just passed
on to us from our parents.
>> John Fenn III: And then
are there younger generations
that you all are working
with to pull in --
maybe not into the group,
because you're not
ready to be done, right?
But pulling into the tradition,
into that brace of music?
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.:
Believe it or not,
we don't see a lot of that.
I'll let Bobbye take
-- talk about that.
>> Bobbye Sherrell:
Yeah, well --
and it is becoming a lost art.
People do -- after they hear us
sing, a lot of young people come
to us and maybe ask us about
how long we've been singing,
but it hasn't gotten to a
point where they're picking
up the style yet, the
acapella, traditional style.
But there are some young
singers, and they are picking
up our vocal controls.
They're listening to us
as if they are curious
about how we make [inaudible],
and how we change a chord
from maybe [inaudible].
But as far as backing
and getting behind
this traditional style,
it's almost a lost art.
But it's in demand, though, so
I don't understand why people --
you know, they want to
hear it, but it seems
like nobody's interested
in learning how to --
>> John Fenn III: Maybe
they're too intimidated.
I mean, because to your point of
how you do some of the chords,
and just listening
to the interaction
of your voices earlier, I'm
curious if you could talk
about how you come up with
some of the arrangements.
What's the process?
What are you listening
to or listening for?
>> Leveret Allison: I
think it has to be --
>> Larrice Byrd,
Sr.: Need a mic.
>> Leveret Allison: I
think you have to be in --
we've listened to this.
The four of us, like we come up
in this, you know, and we got --
kind of got away from it.
Especially Joe and I listened to
the Fairfield Four growing up.
And we got to the music,
and the acapella style kind
of went away.
But like -- we were just always
kind of familiar with it,
but never just really did it.
So like Joe had, but I hadn't.
And so but like I love it.
And the younger people
today, I see some seem
like they're interested in it.
I don't know if they're
going to do it or not.
>> John Fenn III:
Well, let's hope.
And I mean, because
I'm hearing the heavy,
heavy gospel tradition, but
I'm also hearing some other
influences in some of your
arrangements and in some
of your vocal harmonies.
Can anyone speak to where
you're picking that up
or how that's coming in?
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: Well, you
know, we're an acapella group,
so we don't have music.
So we have to create the music.
So you know, and
we have a little --
I have a little musical theory.
So we have to put that
information together
and try to create music.
Of course, you know, the
bass singer keeps the rhythm,
the bump, keep the pulse.
And then we try to concentrate
on fitting those chords
in our voices that's
missing, you know,
so we try to create
vocal singing
and vocal music at
the same time.
>> John Fenn III: Now what --
maybe we can talk a little bit
about the place, Nashville.
It's -- so it's home
to three of you.
And now do you live there?
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: Yeah.
>> John Fenn III: So
you guys are still --
I mean, because the band --
the group has been a
Nashville-based from day one.
>> Leveret Allison: Right.
>> John Fenn III: How has the --
and Nashville is known
as a musical center
for couple different
kinds of music.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: Exactly.
>> John Fenn III: But how has
that environment influenced
the development of the group
over the past 90-odd years?
>> Bobbye Sherrell: You know,
I think seems like to me
that the Fairfield Four sound
was developed in the early '20s,
and we haven't let it go.
It's still a Fairfield
Four sound.
And I think our -- what
we were always trying
to do is just continue to
hold that tradition as just --
like the second generation,
they sounded
like the first generation.
And maybe the first
generation sounded more
like the [inaudible] or
that similar, combination.
That -- what they
found then in the '20s,
we're still holding onto that.
>> John Fenn III: Okay.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: But as
far as the industry itself,
we learned a lot about the fact
that Nashville is
a music center.
You know, we go in studios,
and we learn how to sing,
and what to do, and
when to do it.
I think that's been
a big thing with us.
You know, there's a
million singers out here,
but sometimes you
can overdo this,
or not do enough here and there.
And so being in a music center,
that really does help us.
We see the professionals --
other professionals, you know.
>> John Fenn III: And you've
recorded with some of them
and performed with some of them.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.:
And we pick up stuff.
>> John Fenn III: So there's a
lot of interaction there, huh?
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.:
Yes, great interaction.
>> John Fenn III: Okay, now
earlier I mentioned to you
that back in 1940
on this very stage,
the Golden Gate Quartet
did a version
of "Noah" that you did today.
And so this stage is carrying
this song in many, many ways.
What other kinds of important
moments have you experienced
in performing in
the past eight years
as the current configuration?
What are some highlights?
Some places you've performed
that you just stepped
away and said, "Wow"?
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.:
Well, I remember --
personally I remember in --
we went to Konya, Turkey,
and that festival
consisted of artists
from all around the world.
So they had -- we
represented the United States
as African American music.
But you know, you
had Persian music --
you had every music from
all around the world.
And I learned a lot just from
listening to that experience.
You had -- it sounded like -- I
forget the type of music it was,
but they did -- you
know how he sings low?
>> John Fenn III: Mm-hmm.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: They
were about twice as low,
and it was like a chant.
It was a bunch of [inaudible],
and they sung a chant.
And I had never seen
that before.
>> John Fenn III: Wow.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: But
that's one of the things
that stuck out with me --
>> John Fenn III: Great
experience, yeah --
>> Larrice Byrd,
Sr.: -- my travels.
Experience, yes.
>> John Fenn III: -- through
your music to be able to travel
around and experience
this other stuff.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: Yes.
>> John Fenn III: Anyone else
have any moments that stand
out from your time
with the group that --
>> Bobbye Sherrell: I can
remember how maybe the first two
or three folk festivals we've
done, and the style of music
that they was doing, and I
was grabbing ahold of it.
And then when we did our version
of our gospel, and they seemed
to be amazed, as if we were
sharing some type of a legacy
between us and the people
that played folk music.
So I mean, kind of
like I felt like --
I felt in-place rather than out
of place once we got started.
And we was responding to them
just like they responded to us.
It was an interaction thing,
and I like that feeling,
because when you think about
folk festivals or folk music,
you think about banjos
and upright basses.
But then when we set stage and
got on, it was the same type
of inner vibe that they got
from us as we got from them.
>> John Fenn III: Bringing
another living tradition
to the stage --
>> Bobbye Sherrell: Yes.
>> John Fenn III: -- and
getting that interaction.
Fantastic.
Now -- so the group
has been awarded --
was awarded an NEA National
Heritage Fellowship in 1989;
three Grammys, as you mentioned;
a bunch of other accolades,
Gospel Hall of Fame.
How does that make you feel as
part of this longer tradition
of the Fairfield Four?
>> Joe Thompson: I
feel truly blessed --
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.:
Yes, that's the word.
>> Joe Thompson: -- to
be able to do what we do.
And we try to keep
God in our midst.
This is one of the things that
I think that has helped each one
of us to just stay together
and love one another.
And when you love one another,
and you feel the same, you know,
and our voices just go
along with what we feel.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: Yeah,
I think that's a good word.
We do feel blessed, because
we didn't do anything special
to deserve this spot in this
-- you know, in this time.
So we feel like we've been
picked out to be blessed.
And we really appreciate it.
Try to give God all the
glory and all the praise.
>> Joe Thompson: Amen.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: We
believe he's the reason.
>> Joe Thompson: Amen.
>> Leveret Allison:
In other words,
we don't take any of the credit.
>> John Fenn III: Okay.
>> Leveret Allison:
We give it all to Him.
As long as you put Him first,
you've got to be
going -- do good.
>> John Fenn III: Now how
often do you perform a year?
You guys on the road
constantly, or?
>> Bobbye Sherrell: Believe
it or not, not constantly.
You know, it seems to work
out as it's not hurting
us physically.
We're in and out of
concerts and appearances,
seems to be just enough
to handle our standards
of age and stuff.
You know what I mean?
When it's time to get
some rest, we're off.
And when it's time to get up and
go, then the boots get filled.
So once again, it's by faith
the things that's happening,
even our work, and our
performances, and now being put
on a platform to sing the
Word and to send that message.
Seems like even today
that it was like --
it was just in the nick
of time that we was here
to give them what they wanted,
and they gave us what we wanted.
So it's not -- it's
not by accident.
Seems like it's already
predestined what we need
to be doing, and how we do it,
and how people accept
us and we accept them.
>> John Fenn III: Yeah, it
seemed to me out in the audience
that you all are having
a good time up here.
>> Bobbye Sherrell:
Without a doubt.
>> Joe Thompson: We do.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: We do.
>> John Fenn III: And you were
also giving that and getting
that from the audience.
Is that --
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: Yes.
>> Joe Thompson: Yes.
>> John Fenn III: And it seems
like that's somehow connected
into the gospel tradition, too.
>> Larrice Byrd,
Sr.: Yes, yes, it is.
>> John Fenn III:
Where gospel happens
in the house of worship --
>> Bobbye Sherrell:
At the church, yeah.
>> John Fenn III: Yeah, it's
part of a larger engagement
with the audience, with
God, with your beliefs.
>> Joe Thompson: Right.
>> John Fenn III: And you
bring that to the stage, too.
>> Bobbye Sherrell:
That's our intention.
>> Leveret Allison:
Our full intention,
to bring people to God.
>> John Fenn III:
Well, you've --
>> Joe Thompson: We feel
if we can get one person
to turn their life toward
God, you know, we feel --
we're pleased with what
we do, because this is --
Jesus left a whole
multitude of people and went
across the water to get one.
So if we can save one, we feel
like we're pleased
with what we do.
This is why we enjoy what we do.
>> John Fenn III:
And I'm guessing
that you're still
singing in churches?
>> Joe Thompson: Oh, yes.
Oh, yes.
>> Leveret Allison:
Anywhere we can,
we always try to
bring the church.
We're going to bring the church,
I don't care where we sing.
>> John Fenn III: Yeah, I mean,
again, that's what struck me
from just our hour with you on
this stage as a performance.
It wasn't just a stage concert.
You were in habiting --
>> Leveret Allison: Right.
>> John Fenn III: -- where
you want to be with the music.
>> Leveret Allison: This
is what we're all about.
>> Bobbye Sherrell: And it's
strange that you say that,
because we even do
that when we rehearse.
>> John Fenn III: Okay.
>> Bobbye Sherrell: When we --
we rehearse as if we're
out here doing some things.
And it makes it easier.
We stop and correct
ourselves as we go.
But the whole thing about it is
how we present ourselves before
people, even in between
the songs,
what we're saying,
and how we say it.
Not being offensive, but
we're being ourselves.
And so we practice it.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: We -- the
Bible says, "If I be lifted up,
I'll draw them in," so we're
just making a presentation.
You'll be surprised at
the people who don't know
about the Lord as their savior.
So we make the presentation,
and he'll do the drawing.
You know, we can't do it.
So we just try to
share the Lord Jesus
with everyone we
come in contact with.
>> John Fenn III: And you bring
that into the studio, too.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: Yes.
>> John Fenn III: I mean,
just having listened --
>> Larrice Byrd,
Sr.: Same thing.
>> John Fenn III: -- to
the recordings over time.
So for you, it's all part of
the whole what you're engaged
with as Fairfield Four.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: Yes.
>> John Fenn III: So
we talked about --
a little bit about the younger
generation, but what do you see
as the future of
the Fairfield Four?
What are you guys up to next?
>> Bobbye Sherrell: Well --
>> Leveret Allison: More CDs.
>> John Fenn III: More CDs.
More of the grind.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.:
It's time for another CD,
but I guess we --
believe it or not,
we've talked bout
the next generation.
And we can't see it.
I'm pretty sure the guys
didn't see us coming in.
So we kind of like --
Bobbye made a great comment
that we just leave it up --
let the Lord handle it.
See, he always seems to find --
to put the right
people in place,
and that's how it's
been all along.
It's hard to just go find
exactly what you need
to keep it going, so --
>> Joe Thompson: And it's
funny Brother Byrd said that,
because I didn't
know he could sing.
And -- all I saw him was
playing his music, you know.
And my wife was in
church one day,
and we heard this choral
singing, and we were trying
to find out who was
singing the lead.
Nobody's mouth was moving.
And my wife -- we
peeking around everybody.
And I stood up, and it was Byrd.
I said, "Baby, that
boy can sing!
Listen to him!"
So it was not hard to
just bring him on in
because we was close anyway.
>> John Fenn III: So once
you heard his voice, you --
>> Joe Thompson: Yeah,
when I heard his voice I
said, "Okay, that's him."
>> John Fenn III: Now do any
of you have a favorite song
to perform, whether
you're in church,
or onstage, or in the studio?
Something that you
just -- is a go-to?
>> Leveret Allison:
It's hard to --
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: It's hard.
>> Leveret Allison: --
pick up a favorite song
when you've been
singing as long --
especially as long as Joe and I.
It's hard to do that, you
know, because I like all kinds
of music and all kinds of songs.
And just to pick one
favorite, I don't --
huh-uh, I can't really do that.
>> Joe Thompson: I
have one favorite.
In my church, I open up
service just about every Sunday.
And it's "Jesus Keep
Me Near the Cross."
That has been closer to
me than any of the others.
And I don't know, I just
-- my pastor's wife says,
"Deacon Thompson, I believe
that's your favorite song,
because you sing
that all the time."
I say, "Yes, ma'am.
I do."
>> John Fenn III: Is there a
song that maybe has traveled
through all three generations
of the Fairfield Four
that you would -- anyone
would identify as a --
I mean, there's a
Fairfield Four sound,
but is there a song
that maybe has --
>> Leveret Allison: Yes,
that "Dig a Little Deeper."
>> Joe Thompson: And that "Don't
Let Nobody Turn You Around."
>> Leveret Allison: And "Don't
>> John Fenn III: Okay.
>> Leveret Allison: I grew up
listening to those two songs
from the Fairfield Four.
>> John Fenn III: And now you --
>> Leveret Allison:
That's the sound.
>> John Fenn III: -- now
you perform those songs.
>> Leveret Allison:
Right, right.
>> John Fenn III: Yeah,
that's pretty amazing to me
that that -- again, that sort
of generational rejuvenation
and joy that comes
through the performance.
I definitely heard it.
I heard that.
>> Leveret Allison: Okay.
>> John Fenn III: So you said
you enjoy all kinds of music,
and those of you who
identify as musicians --
although, I think
you're all musicians --
>> Leveret Allison:
I even hear music
that I don't understand
what they're saying,
different language,
but something
about the music just seems
to just grab hold to you.
>> John Fenn III: And do
you try to bring those ideas
into what you're doing?
I mean, you're carrying on a
tradition, but you're also --
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.:
You do it unconsciously.
You do it unconsciously,
you know,
because if you hear something
that you really like,
it's hard to just get -- throw
it out of your mind like.
So you can easily do it
unconsciously, bring in an idea.
I'm a rhythm guy, and I just
-- I hear stuff, and I just --
you have to ring
it in, you know.
Try to squeeze it in -- get
it in, make it fit somewhere.
>> John Fenn III: And it seems
like to me that's also part
of the larger tradition
of gospel,
which incorporates a whole bunch
of different musical
influences and ideas --
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: Exactly.
>> John Fenn III: -- but always
toward a goal or a purpose, too,
given where the tradition
comes from.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: Yes, yes.
>> John Fenn III: And that
resonates with your experiences?
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: Yes.
Yes, it does.
>> John Fenn III: Excellent.
Now I have to ask about "O,
Brother, Where Art Thou?"
Because you brought
it up onstage.
And so who was in -- who
appeared in the movie?
>> Bobbye Sherrell: None of us.
>> Joe Thompson:
Neither one of us.
>> John Fenn III: Okay,
I didn't think so.
But how -- so how do you
carry that mantle, too?
I mean, the Fairfield Four is
known as being in that movie.
And they were in the movie, but
it was the previous generation.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.:
Exact -- second generation.
>> Bobbye Sherrell: But
we still got the sound.
>> John Fenn III: Maybe they
need to do like a reboot
of the movie and
have you guys --
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.:
That would be good.
>> Bobbye Sherrell: Yeah.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.:
That would be great.
>> John Fenn III: Because your
version of that song, I mean,
was so wonderful, too.
So did you learn that as growing
up with the Fairfield Four?
Or did you kind of
bring that in --
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: Yeah, we
decided to sing that song --
learn it and sing it because
there's so many people
that identify with the
Fairfield Four in that movie.
So -- and we're the
Fairfield Four.
We have to --
>> John Fenn III: You have
a responsibility, of sorts.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: Yeah,
some type of responsibility to.
>> John Fenn III: And so when
you go about learning a tune
like that -- so that
might have --
that was a new one for you four
-- you listen to the recordings,
you -- how do you go
about learning a new
song, a new arrangement?
>> Larrice Byrd,
Sr.: Listen to it.
And then when we
listen to a song,
each one of us know our parts.
We can hear our part.
You know, the bass -- it's easy
to pick out the bass singer.
It's the bottom note.
And the top note is
the -- so it's --
and we have to feel
our -- find ours.
Bobbye and I have to find ours.
>> John Fenn III: The middle.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.:
Middle section, yes.
But it's fairly easy since
we've been doing it a while.
You know, we can hear
what's going on in there.
>> John Fenn III: So you all
can just lock in to harmonies
and parts with each other --
>> Bobbye Sherrell:
and even that song,
we put our own twist
on it, on the end.
So we added a little
something of ours,
but that makes it
Fairfield Four.
>> Leveret Allison: Got
to be Fairfield Four.
>> John Fenn III:
It's got to be.
So let's see, what else don't
we know about the Fairfield Four
and the legacy, in even
like the current generation?
You know, what -- what
should people know?
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: Well,
I'll start this one off.
Well, I'm more of
a musician myself.
These guys gave me a chance
to sing, and I love doing it.
But my background is pretty much
the rhythm sections in a band.
And that's where I started.
I started playing in church
where I was a little boy.
And my parents -- my
mother was at a type church
that they called a Sanctified
church back in those days.
And they didn't have
a whole band,
but you could always
usually hear a snare drum
and a tambourine always beating.
Okay, you would hear a guitar
here and there and organs here
and there at these --
they called them
Sanctified Holiness churches.
There was a man in
this one church
that just weared [sic]
out -- a guitar out.
And once I heard that, I just
fell in love with the guitar.
And of course, I got
one soon after that.
My mother made me --
she made me promise
that if she bought one,
I'd learn to play it.
And I did learn to play it.
So that's where I got
started, and it's stuck
with me all these
years, playing --
>> John Fenn III:
And you're still --
are you working on music
outside of the Fairfield Four?
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: Yes, I
play organ for two churches,
so that's what I'm doing
when I'm not out here.
In Nashville.
>> John Fenn III: You're busy.
>> Larrice Byrd,
Sr.: Yeah, I'm busy.
>> John Fenn III: Now, and --
well, you bring up a good point,
though, about -- and
it came up earlier.
There is no band.
You are the band.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: Yes.
>> John Fenn III: And
the rhythmic component is
so crucial.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: Yes.
>> John Fenn III: And
I was hearing a lot
of interesting sort of
syncopations and rhythmic stuff
across the vocal parts.
And that's -- I mean, that's
something you have to work on.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.:
You have to work on it.
It's not as easy as it seems.
>> John Fenn III: No.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: No.
>> Joe Thompson: Thanks to
Brother Bobbye for that.
He keeps us all in check.
>> John Fenn III: He keeps
the rhythms moving around?
>> Joe Thompson: Oh, yes, yes.
He's one of us.
>> Leveret Allison: Well,
some people think this
is real easy to do.
It's not.
>> John Fenn III: They
haven't tried, huh?
>> Leveret Allison: Right.
>> John Fenn III: No, I mean,
you all make it look so easy,
but that's because you're --
like you said, you've been
doing it your whole lives
in some form or another.
>> Leveret Allison: Yes.
>> John Fenn III: But it
does take the practice.
So you guys are rehearsing
and --
>> Joe Thompson: Right.
>> John Fenn III: -- continuing
to sing in church, and --
>> Joe Thompson: And
when you love one another
as we love each other, it's easy
to get stuff pretty
well together,
because we don't get
angry with each other.
You know, of one
makes a mistake --
and Brother Bobbye can
catch us right quick.
And you know, he tells us, "Hey,
you need to do such-and-such
thing right here."
"Okay, show it to me."
And that's how we gel
together, one in unity.
We are all four in unity,
and we try to keep God
in our midst, as
our main chorus.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: So
are you wanting to know
about the other guys'
backgrounds?
>> John Fenn III: Yeah.
>> Bobbye Sherrell: Go ahead.
>> Leveret Allison: Background?
Brother Joe kind
of started it off.
We all just about got the same
kind of growing up, families.
My brother was a singer.
Had an uncle that was a singer.
My mother was a singer.
And it just stayed with me.
I started singing when I was
about five or six years old.
And at the age of
12, I was singing
with my uncle's gospel
group as a lead singer.
And I just kept on and on
there, just always been in me.
>> John Fenn III: And this was
in Nashville -- the
Nashville area?
>> Leveret Allison:
In Nashville, yeah.
That's where I was born and
raised, in Nashville, right.
>> John Fenn III: What
about your background?
>> Bobbye Sherrell: I
myself, yeah, I started early.
My mother, she was a
choir leader and director.
And she had me sing -- she
had us -- there was 12 of us,
so she had all of us brothers
and sisters singing
at an early age.
I think I was five years old
when I started singing --
five and six at church.
And picking up instruments
from the junior high.
I was in the band, and
one thing led to another.
I started singing some
other secular music.
And I got lost somewhere,
but love brought me back.
I got back in church, and now
I'm a praise and worship leader
at my church, and do the male
chorus, and the mass choir
when we're not here doing this.
So I'm -- I think I -- I got
lost, like we all do sometimes,
but then I got found again.
So the purpose that He had for
me is, I just had to settle down
and let Him have His way.
And I'm grateful.
The opportunities
and the chances
that we have together
as the four of us.
They're like brothers to
me, and we work like a unit.
So --
>> Larrice Byrd,
Sr.: We are a unit.
>> Bobbye Sherrell:
Yeah, and right now,
what you're saying
is -- well, what --
my background is right
here, what you see.
It just took a while to get
it together, but this is it.
This is just -- this is
what it molded out to be.
and I'm grateful
for Fairfield Four.
>> John Fenn III: So I want
to ask about the arrangement
of "Amazing Grace," as you
bring up lost and found,
because that arrangement, it
wasn't one I've heard before.
I mean, it was amazing.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: Thank you.
>> John Fenn III: But so yeah,
did you all work
that arrangement out?
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.: We did.
>> Leveret Allison: We did.
>> John Fenn III: What --
>> John Fenn III: What was
driving that arrangement?
What was the inspiration?
>> Bobbye Sherrell: We
had church on our mind.
It was -- I think somebody
requested that song that we do.
And we were sitting down
one day in rehearsal --
>> Joe Thompson: Right.
>> Bobbye Sherrell: -- and we
just took our time and just --
we all went to church
that night.
And we just slowed it down and
just actually told a story.
And I think if the truth be
known, tears came upon my eyes,
because the way we
did it, you had to --
we had to think about the song
-- more than just singing it
but telling the story.
And things flashing
back in your mind.
And it is amazing --
His grace is amazing.
>> John Fenn III: Yeah, that
was a moving arrangement.
>> Bobbye Sherrell: Yeah, so
we give all the credit for that
because all of us had a
thumb and a finger in that.
But that's Fairfield
Four for you.
>> Leveret Allison:
Yeah, that's just us.
>> Larrice Byrd,
Sr.: And we look back
on our lives in this group.
You know, this group
of guys right here,
we never would have come
together as a group.
We were all doing
different things completely,
going other ways.
But here we are, look.
And it's working just fine.
It's great.
A good relationship --
good working relationship,
and it's just working fine.
>> Joe Thompson: I'm pointing
up because it's nobody but God.
>> John Fenn III:
There's nothing else,
huh, to explain it?
>> Joe Thompson: He's got
-- He put us all together.
Not we ourselves -- God did.
That's the way we feel about it.
>> John Fenn III: Well, I want
to thank you for taking the time
to do this interview here.
Any final thoughts
on performing here
on the Coolidge Stage, or --
>> Bobbye Sherrell: Well,
we want to thank you all
for having us, and
the interview.
It's still a learning
experience for me,
and what you're bringing
is even helping us more.
>> John Fenn III: Well --
>> Bobbye Sherrell:
We're still growing.
>> John Fenn III:
That's humbling.
>> Leveret Allison: And
we want to thank you
for doing this interview.
It was an honor for us to
be here and to do this.
>> Larrice Byrd, Sr.:
And we pray that we --
this interview and our singing
and praises help somebody
else along the way, find --
>> Joe Thompson: Amen, amen.
>> John Fenn III: Well, it
was definitely a great gift,
so thank you very much.
>> All: Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.